I was initially gonna cover this topic
what I do think is interesting here what
I do want to talk about it's it's people
who preach something and then backtrack
back battle flippy-floppy pretty much
switz petha shop we should ask you about
the Gabrielle Union controversy of
course there are reports that our
contract wasn't renewed because she
reported a toxic atmosphere existed at
this show here at the show is is there a
toxic atmosphere first of all I can't
speak for exorcism cuz I'm not a woman
you know what let's just let them talk
if you don't say anything you are by
your silence it's a substance and I I'm
not gonna be silent I I'm not gonna be
silent but they they need a man like me
to say something I've always said that
men need to hold other men accountable
that is the only way the system is going
to change behavior if another man can
come up to a man and say we don't do
that we're not allowing that here all of
a sudden the culture will begin to
change and if I have to be the first one
that's gonna do it then let it be I will
be that one what happened Terry you got
a job my thing is you know it's funny
because I believe you should listen to
women you should always believe women so
I asked my wife what I should do that's
a confusing respect Oh your wife is not
every woman but Whitney Houston is
[Music]
[Laughter]
but the wife is not the one sock you
know believe our woman Stephanie if it's
coming from an unnamed source because
Gabrielle Union has not made any
statement to this day about any of these
allegations publicly that's interesting
to me so Terry Crews can't understand
why someone wouldn't want to go public
with what they're saying Terry Crews if
you remember had an incident while back
when he was at a festival and someone
grabbed his car right and he made a big
stink about it years later here's what
he said one thing that people don't
understand about this movement is that
people think that people come forward to
get money people come forward to get
Fame the deal is you only get paid for
your silence when something happened to
me I did come for right away I went
right to the agency where this man
worked and told everybody but I didn't
go public right away I gave them time to
rectify the situation I wanted them to
get rid of this man isn't that literally
what Gabrielle Union is doing right now
brother not only do I want a full refund
I want your manager to call their
manager and I want them to call me
tomorrow
I want a gift card oh you were full
caring on them that's right never go for
cash no listen let's keep watching
because Terry's not done putting his
foot in his mouth
that's a big foot had to support these
women who were being told that they were
opportunists that they were liars
that they just were looking for a payday
one thing that I faced when I came
forward with my story
she was ostracism I didn't like the
shame by people who look just like me my
wife said well she hasn't made a
statement why would you yeah oh god I
said you know what I will listen to her
Terry domini car wants to know who
supports surprised you the most when you
spoke out about the thought that you
experienced you know be honest with you
the people who surprised me the most
were black women really oh all my
support came from black women straight
up that's so nice
Wow it was it shocked me it shocked mom
no you're not drinking apple cider
vinegar are you yeah throw your breath
right now I'm getting second degree
apple cider vinegar if I get in the
business everybody yes black men did not
want any part of it and ladies now you
know why we didn't support him I never
liked Terry Crews never never I mean as
an actor I was indifferent but once he
became a social activist I was not on
board with it you know there's something
about the male feminist types that are
always shucking and jiving when it's
front of the cameras soon as things get
tough
they either turn out to be the
Weinsteins or they turn out to be
flip-floppers and I'm like bro you're
not a sandal don't flip-flop
okay wet noodles out here I'm not with
that noodle
this is something I've grown to really
hate over time I don't care if you don't
have strong opinions about stuff I don't
care if you're not allowed about your
views that's okay if you're that way
that's fine
what I cannot stand or people who preach
or religion but don't believe in the
face bro you're asking me to take a leap
but you're not willing to take it
yourself the moment that your money's
threatened you flip-flop like this I got
a huge problem with that what did I say
I'm like listen brother if you claim you
got values but the moment things get
tough the moment money's on the line you
drop those values you don't have values
no you got ideas you got ideas you love
to talk about but you don't believe it
he said and after everyone came out him
this way said there is one only one
woman on this earth I have to please her
name is Rebecca not my mother not my
sister my daughters or coworkers I will
let their husbands and boyfriends and
partners take care of them
Rebecca gives me wings is your wife Red
Bull what the [ __ ] are you talking about
bro listen you're saying that the only
time women need defending is if they got
a partner so what about all the single
women out there um what do you talk
about just what about all the women who
are in relationships with people who are
what are you singing bro me from those
fans the problem here is not you know
this man or or or masculine this this is
just a matter of people with low
character preaching like they got high
character
you know Kari played a supporting role
in the show he was the father and
everybody hates chris yeah but now he's
the lead actor and everybody hates Terry
Wow I can't speak on behalf of Hanny
some comments that was never my
experience on America's Got Talent
it was the most diverse place I have
ever been in my 20 years of
entertainment between the top ten acts
were Asian women older younger black why
it was everything in the gap diversity
is about understanding different
people's perspectives and taking into
consideration in the decision-making you
don't have to be black to make a
decision that benefits black people if
you understand them and understand their
cultural sensibilities then you can help
people integrate into the workforce
so for me I don't care if 70 of the
executives are black or white it doesn't
matter there's plenty of times where you
have black owners and black people in
charge and they don't do a good job of
encouraging an inclusive works for
example if we were integrating women
into the workforce and we're like ladies
come work with us but we had no women's
restroom and we're like we're not
interested in that then you see how you
create limitations diversity is not
about who you sprinkle into your mosaic
it's about where they come from and
understanding that but you do have to at
some point cater to the people that you
take decisions for them
I mean example if you decide to hire and
get people what happened to Terry Terry
didn't come to work there's no ramp for
Terry to come to work Terry can't come
to work because it's not a mother ramp
oh yes you hired Terry but cannot even
get there and look I'm not even saying
that you're have to have a diverse work
space but this is what NBC preaches this
is what NBC loves to put out there so
I'm like if you go
put it out there don't be about what you
want to work right this is this one
tomba again these are not my values
these are the values they claim to
expose so I'm like cool
then live by those values that's all I
ask of people it's like don't be preachy
don't create a media conglomerate who
lusts to preach to the people and then
you don't live by the values you click
people want to talk about the Gabrielle
Union she deserved to be let go there's
not enough information for me to say 100
because it's just the base what I
thought I read some of the comments who
she receives like her hair was too black
which if it's true I don't know what
that means or what they're trying to say
your hair is too black yes there was a
couple of other insensitive moments like
apparently one of the performers was
doing like celebrity impressions and
then at one point he changed his outfit
you came out like Beyonce but he he
pulled a Justin Trudeau on his hands and
made them extra time and she's like yo
y'all got to cut this man now and like
we'll see about that later so she got
mad about that apparently she's allergic
to smoke and Simon Cowell smokes all the
time on the show on the show she's
allergic and look that one he runs the
show NBC can't do anything about him but
people wanna get mad at her be like yeah
you can't say that to the guy who runs
the show but NBC's already tried to make
him stop so her reiterating that I don't
know how that makes her difficult do you
know what I'm saying and then she got
mad at G Leno because he made a joke
about how Simon had a image with dogs
and it looked like it looked like an
image that someone from career would
have because you know they eat dogs or
whatever mmm that's a joke I'm not
veneer I don't cosign you're reporting
him for a joke like that because when
it's factual - it's a joke and three
he's a comedian
calm down so look whether or not she
deserve to get fired that's ambiguous
there's arguments for arguments against
but Terry is garbage and I don't like
Terry cuz this is not the first time
he's done some wack [ __ ] like this right
when that do touched his cojones right
he's like I couldn't do anything I was
so hurt and everyone jumped and black
men were like yo why don't you just put
his lights out right like why don't you
just stand your ground when someone put
their hands on you and you know what he
did she responds you DL Hughley by
saying what if I saw you next time and I
slap you in the face
so I'm like wait you gonna slap deal
Hughley for saying you should defend
yourself but you're not gonna slap the
man who touched you I hope
whatever and then Terry later on came
out the same boys young children need a
father figure in their life and I was
like yeah Terry I agree with you
then feminists came out him and he's
like I apologize I should not have
imagined the wording the wording is he
the weight of wording words the wedding
was not yeah you get this guy off my
screen flips